261,000 people watched our video from
three weeks ago that told you guys not
to buy a MacBook Pro just yet so if
you're one of those people
congratulations because Apple just
surprised everyone with the brand-new
twenty twenty thirteen inch MacBook Pros
so in this video we're gonna talk about
every single change to each of the new
13-inch models we'll discuss why there's
no fourteen inch macbook pro like some
expected and we'll talk about the other
reason why there are a lot of people
that are hugely disappointed in this
refresh but before we get into the bad
news let's talk about the good news
because it's Monday and we want our good
news both the new 13-inch models now
come with a new magic keyboard which is
the most important change because the
old Butterfly keyboard in the previous
model was carrying around a horrible
reputation for being unreliable to
quickly sum up the issue if dust or
debris got under the keyboard it could
stop some of the keys from working so
the new magic keyboard completely fixes
that but it also feels so much better
than type on since it has a lot more key
travel so it's a night and day
difference and there might even be some
people upgrading just for the keyboard
alone other than that the rest of the
changes are on the inside meaning that
the display and everything else about it
is identical for the $1,300 model the
great news is that you now get 256 gigs
of storage at the base price compared to
only 128 last year so this new model
basically matches up to last year's
$1500 model and you get a better
keyboard and one huge change is that
it's now only a $100 upgrade to get 16
gigs of RAM
compared to $200 last year now if you
don't know if that upgrade is worth it
for you I'm actually making a buyer's
upgrade guide right now which will help
you decide which model in which upgrades
you should buy so if you're not already
subscribed click that subscribe button
below and make sure you have that Bell
icon clicked as well so you don't miss
out on that video and that's basically
the only changes coming to the base
$1300 13 inch macbook pro but the
higher-end
hundred dollar model is where the real
fun starts the biggest change is the
upgrade to intel's new quad core 10 gen
processors which use the new 10
nanometers process and technology so
it's going to be more efficient and more
powerful than before with this also
comes new integrated graphics that are
much faster as well so this will be huge
for those who do a lot of graphics work
it now comes with a 512 gig SSD at the
base $1,800 price which is a huge change
because that's what the 16 inch macbook
pro comes with and you can also now
upgrade it to a huge 4 terabytes of
storage and another big change is that
it already comes with 16 gigs of even
faster 3733 megahertz ram whereas last
year it only came with 8 gigs of slower
ram and you had to pay an extra 200
dollars to upgrade to 16 so there will
be huge changes to our buyer's guide
this year so stay tuned for that apart
from those changes the only other real
change is that this eighteen hundred
dollar model can now support a 6k
display which means it can now power
apple's new pro display XDR so that's it
for the good news now let's get into why
people are disappointed the main reason
is that the base $1300 model still comes
with the same old 8th gen processor that
we had last year which is really
disappointing since the 20/20 MacBook
Air comes with 10th gen across-the-board
and the price dropped by $100 while this
MacBook Pro stayed at the same price
which is the second reason why people
are disappointed however we still
recommend this 8th gen chip over the new
tension ships in the MacBook Air because
Apple chose not to connect the fan to
the processors heatsink so this MacBook
Pro will still run circles around it as
we discussed in our video from yesterday
and lastly we're still not getting Wi-Fi
6 on either of these models so that's
quite a bit disappointing so now the
question is why would Apple leave the
base model with the 8th gen chip well
for the past year before today's refresh
we've been recommending everyone to just
buy the $1300 MacBook Pro
model and completely skip out on the
more expensive $1,800 model if you want
more performance because there honestly
wasn't a very big jump in performance
going for that more expensive model
which is obviously bad news for Apple
but now there is actually a huge
difference between these two so spending
the extra cash
on the better model actually makes sense
for some people unlike last year where
it made more sense to just go straight
for the 16 inch MacBook Pro and another
reason why Apple left the 8th gen chip
is because of the rumored fourteen point
one inch MacBook Pro that will be coming
either at the end of this year or
sometime early next year if there are
production delays but we expect as the
Apple is only going to upgrade the
current $1,800 MacBook Pro to the new
fourteen point one inch model and leave
the base $1300 model alone this will
give them the opportunity to upgrade the
13-inch model to the ten gen processors
at the same time as they release the
$1,800 fourteen point one inch MacBook
Pro so maybe that's why they left the
8th gen chip for right now and then a
year after that they'll finally upgrade
the lower end $1,300 MacBook Pro to the
new fourteen point one inch design of
course this really sucks for US
consumers but Apple's gonna do what
they're gonna do to incentivize their
more expensive laptops and maximize
their profits so if you've been waiting
for the 20/20 MacBook Pro and you're
wondering which model to buy click the
circle above right now to subscribe
because our buyers upgrade guide video
is coming out tomorrow thanks for
watching and we'll see you tomorrow
[Music]